police in Moscow Idaho worked their way
through the holiday digging their way
through email photo and phone tips
hoping to spot even a tiny clue that
might Point them to our hoop toward them
who killed University of Idaho students
in November now Ben Mogan the father of
victim Madison Logan says he's confident
that the murderer will be found and
brought to Justice Mogan spoke with the
newspaper out in Washington state saying
that there's just too much information
available like DNA and videos for
someone to just get away Madison Mogan
her best friend Kaylee gonsalves their
roommate zonnica nodal and zana's
boyfriend Ethan Chapin were stabbed to
death inside an off-campus home on
November 13th so far no public no
suspects have been publicly identified
and police have not found the murder
weapon
but just weeks before her death Kaylee
Gonzalez and her boyfriend Jack Decor
ended their five-year relationship now
because of that many online slaves
appointed the finger at him for the
quadruple murder decor's Aunt spoke to
the New York Post saying that the split
was amicable Decor was investigated but
Moscow police say he was cleared
Kaylee's family has also shown its
support for Decor saying he's not
involved but one internet investigator
is in some very serious hot water after
connecting a University of Idaho
Professor to the brutal killings Ashley
Gallard posted multiple Tick-Tock videos
saying Professor Rebecca Schofield was
the perpetrator galard says she solves
crimes online through psychic readings
she claims Schofield was in a
relationship with one of the victims and
when that victim wanted to take a break
Scofield plotted the murder Scofield of
course wanted gulillard to take the
videos down in which she didn't Scofield
sued Scofield says not only did she not
know any of the victims or have them in
her classes but she and her husband were
in Oregon on November 13th Gallard who
lives in Texas has continued to post
about Schofield saying she's looking
forward to seeing her in court Brian
short of the suspect's identity what do
you think could help break this case
open now well I'm also using my psychic
reading of touching my lawn crime cup
but that aside I'm thinking it's the
murder weapon in most criminal cases
when you find the murder weapon
especially in a case like this where we
hear the stab wounds are so unique
that's the connective tissue between the
actual killing of the victims and that
of the killer if we can find the weapon
know its uniqueness understand where it
may be how it was used maybe how it was
purchased that would give us a lot more
the DNA is helpful the video is helpful
but I'm looking for that murder weapon I
think that's going to really crack this
case open so Terry I mentioned that
social media they're targeting the
ex-boyfriend of Kaylee Gonzalez as the
possible murderer he was already cleared
by police but did authorities clear him
too quickly listen I definitely think
they're clearing everybody way too
quickly I don't think that the former
boyfriend Jack is the suspect but still
they have to dig deep they keep clearing
everyone they cleared the two roommates
very quickly almost immediately they
cleared everyone who might have been in
that white car they cleared almost
everyone that they've talked to so far
and what they need to do in my opinion
is stop clearing everybody you have to
dig deep even if there is an alibi then
what if somebody set it up you dig
deeper than just saying okay where were
you the day of now I don't know what
their questioning was but I do think
that they are looking at all of these
various suspects and they basically are
just wiping them off their list and I
think that's part of the problem I think
that's why it's taking so long I think
they need to go into each of those
suspects what were they doing that day
what phone records all of it just to
make sure before they clear these people
that they're actually someone to clear
but maybe they did that Terry and if
they didn't clear them and say don't
look that way what would online slues be
doing that at that point right and so
it's you know it's hard game to play
right now but I can kind of understand
where they're coming from as well well a
former Child Star is pleaded not guilty
to assault charges after allegedly
threatening a relative with a hammer and
knife Orlando Brown was best known for
the show That's So Raven on Disney
Channel the family member Brown was
staying with an Ohio told police that he
thought the 35 year old was going to
assault him he's charged with aggravated
menacing and he's being held on twenty
five thousand dollars Bond well another
That's So Raven child star is also
facing legal trouble Kyle Massey is
awaiting a court date after allegedly
sending a sexually explicit video to a
young girl the 13 year old sued Massey
for 1.5 million dollars claiming he sent
her explicit videos photos and messages
through Snapchat in 2018 and 2019.
nassie has denied the allegations the
Bell project an organization that helped
bail people out of jail is shutting down
its Las Vegas office and one of the men
that they helped release shot someone
that's right the bail project was found
in 27 17 and it's backed by celebrities
like Richard Branson John Legend and
Danny Glover the organization says it
has helped more than seven thousand
people get the money they need to get
out of jail Advocates argue that bail is
inherently discriminatory because if you
take two people who committed the same
crime but one doesn't have cash to put
up that person stays Behind Bars before
the trial but last year the bail project
posted a three thousand dollar bail for
Rashawn Gaston Anderson and less than a
week later he shot a waiter seven times
during an attempted burglary now he took
a plea deal getting 7 to 18 years in
prison but the victim sued the bow
project and it turns out the Bell
project had another big problem because
it was it was reportedly not registered
with the state
there's a question as to whether or not
the fact that the technicality of this
particular organization not being
registered
in Nevada the way that they needed to be
like other bail companies would end up
making a difference okay there would be
some particular penalty probably related
to them operating as a bail provider
when they weren't supposed to just like
every other company if I'm Joe's Bail
Bonds I have to have certain uh you know
licensures Etc and apparently this
organization did not check that box but
it would be still be a very very long
stretch I would believe uh for them them
to be liable for what this individual
ends up doing when they they were
released uh pursuant to
um a valid bail amount
Terry you think this Bell project should
have been shut down I mean what else
could they have done to protect
themselves from liability here well this
particular office had to shut down at
least for the time being because they
weren't registered but I think that at
the end of the day I agree I don't think
that they're going to lose as far as
that case is concerned because it is not
their responsibility they don't have
that Duty owed they need to have their
licenses but they don't have to
guarantee that anyone they let out of
jail based on the fact that they paid is
not going to commit another crime I do
think that the judge here in this case
should have looked at the background of
this individual and if there was
criminal behind that you know violent
you know act then I think he shouldn't
have been let out now having said all
that should the company have done due
diligence yes for them to have a
reputation that they are helping people
they need to make sure the people they
help deserve getting out of jail so here
I think they didn't pick the right
person but they're not liable for it so
Brian you had mentioned that Gaston
Anderson's bail of three thousand
dollars actually tells us a lot about
the case how is that exactly so judges
are setting bail based on two things
based on more than two things actually
the crime their history and every other
state except New York does this thing
where they actually set bail based on
their potential danger when you hear a
three thousand dollar bail that means
the judge has already done their due
diligence and doesn't think this person
is a danger to society whether it be
someone paying three thousand dollars or
you're going to a bonds person where you
get to pay 15 of that so what if it's
three thousand you pay 450 and you got
to put up the other two hundred two
thousand five hundred and fifty in
collateral that's a small amount when
you're thinking about Bond and that's
reflective of what the evidence was
against him this isn't a bail bonds
person issue this isn't a celebrity bail
project issue if anything it's the judge
who said a low bail
um put the impetus on the judge great
quick math there Brian I would have been
lost so I'm glad you handled them
lawyers we're not good with numbers what
can I say well a brand new documentary
is going to Chronicle the end of a
celebrity relationship that dominated
the entertainment World former NBA star
Lamar Odom is now teaming up with TMZ to
talk about his divorce from you guessed
it Khloe Kardashian
you kind of backslid into drugs during
this time
that was my girlfriend
I had a wife
um cocaine she stood by you
yes he did
to change that y'all think y'all know
it's crazy
but the stories that y'all don't know is
like is that like really crazy
the couple's Rocky marriage frequently
made headlines more than five years ago
with Odom's drug and sex Edition
addiction at the Forefront Odom was
arrested in 2013 for a DUI and had a
near fatal overdose at a brothel two
years later he also found himself at the
center of several Affairs the
documentary titled sex drugs and
Kardashians aims to tell Odom's side of
the story from Rock Bottom to Redemption
and it premieres on Monday
meanwhile part of Tiger King Joe Exotics
Redemption plan is dead in the water a
federal appeals court has rejected his
request for a new sentence the former
Oklahoma zookeeper and Netflix star is
currently serving 21 years in prison
after he was convicted in 2019 of two
murder For Hire plots against his rival
animal rights activist Carol Baskin now
defense attorneys argued that imposing
consecutive prison terms violates Double
Jeopardy but the U.S Circuit Court of
Appeals disagreed since the murder for
hires charges involve distinct plots
while exotic sentence will remain the
same his request for a new trial
altogether is pending and we have an
update for you on Jen Shaw reality TV
star from The Real Housewives of Salt
Lake City we now know she could face a
decade in prison for wire fraud the 49
year old pleaded guilty to the charge in
July a week before her scheduled trial
now Shaw agreed to Forfeit and pay
restitution in the millions after the
U.S attorney's office accused her of
laundering money through the sale of
lead lists those lists included innocent
people who became scam targeted since
Shaw's alleged telemarketing scheme
Shaw's team is requesting a three-year
prison term citing her lack of criminal
history and lack of direct involvement
in the scheme her sentencing is
scheduled for next